at least five people have been killed in
a mass shooting in the US city of
Milwaukee the attack took place at the
headquarters of the Molson Coors Brewing
Company police are saying the shooter is
dead cher Burton C has more on how the
incident played out soon after two
o'clock in the afternoon Milwaukee
police arrived at the sprawling Molson
Coors brewery and corporate officers
we're over a thousand people work and
there they found the body of a 51 year
old man a Milwaukee man dead of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound and five
others also killed all were employees of
the company no injured were found
several hours later the leftenant
governor of wisconsin lamented gun
violence in his state this is the
eleventh mass shooting in our state
since 2004 and I especially want to
thank the first responders who so
bravely are still responding to the
situation I want to offer my condolences
to the families the friends the
co-workers of everybody involved but I
also want to issue a call a challenge
because we shouldn't accept this this is
not the way the things should be and we
should never grow comfortable in the
face of these repeated tragedies all
across America and especially right here
at home we have a duty to act we have to
be more responsible and as we often see
after a mass shooting this one is
already factoring into the national
debate over gun violence in the United
States the Democratic presidential
candidates saying that they will tackle
the problem if they were to become
presidents something we can hear more of
I'm sure in the summertime when the
Democratic National Convention is held
in Milwaukee however if the past is
anything to go by what normally happens
is we hear a lot of debate a lot of
hand-wringing but in fact gun sales tend
to spike after a mass shooting as
potential gun owners get worried about
more regulation